consult your witch lawyer and check your
significant other for birthmarks because
it's episode three of the chilling
Adventures of Sabrina and we've been
summoned episode three starts where we
left off last episode with Sabrina
running from Dark Lord Hawthorne to puke
out the image of her bloody eyed mouth
foam possessed principle as Sabrina
washes out her mouth she gets a jump
scare from Miss Ward well she continues
to show care and concern for Sabrina and
offers to call her aunts to take her
home a tactic she's employing to try and
gain Sabrina's confidence back of the
Spellman house Ambrose finds an iguana
resting on Connor the Dead warlocks
casket you'll remember Connors mortal
parents mentioned he had a close
connection with an iguana
Ambrose believed to be as familiar and
the familiar has made its way back to
him Ambrose wants to get the iguana
talking and Zelda mentions he isn't
allowed a familiar based on the rules of
his house arrest she also breaks the
news that the familiar will soon die as
they are bound to their witches and
cannot bear in existence without their
master but Ambrose still wants to try
back at Baxter hi Sabrina has an
out-of-body experience before Harvey
snaps her back and Roz storms inventing
that the fascist mr. garland has
rejected her book assignment on The
Bluest Eye The Bluest Eye is a book by
American novelist and teacher Toni
Morrison which centers around an
african-american girl named Pecola in
1941 Ohio during the Great Depression
because of the color of her skin and the
way she acts she is often regarded as
ugly and desires to beautify herself by
gaining blue eyes a trait typically
attributed to white people Wicca decides
to take the fight to Hawthorne witch
Sabrina's a little more hesitant about
now that he foams from the mouth and
wants her soul Hawthorne stands by mr.
Garland's ban which only ignites the
members of Wicca to action
Ross checks the library for more quote
controversial books only to find them
missing when they asked miss Curtis the
librarian where they went she tells the
girls they were soft purged as bad books
but Sabrina's got bigger problems
she's received an infernal summons and
been charged by the Dark Lord and the
coven with a breach of promise from the
Middle Ages up until the 20th century in
many parts of the world a man's mere
promise to marry a woman was considered
a legally binding contract if the man
were to then change his mind it would be
in breach of this contract and he would
be subject to litigate
for damages fun fact a large number of
states in the u.s. still allowed reach
of promise suits according to the
national paralegal college including
settlements awarded of a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars in North
Carolina and a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars in Georgia but laws and
regulations on such suits vary from
state to state and I doubt he'll has a
lot of protections in place for those
who breach promise with the devil
turns out sabrina has been summoned to
the court of witches to face those
charges something no Spelman has ever
been forced to do Zelda and Hilda as
Sabrina's legal guardians are also
responsible for Sabrina's actions and as
a result have lost their witchly powers
and begun to age rapidly were see at
which law states that the accused is
guilty until proven innocent so it's up
to Sabrina to prove she made no breach
of promise or else and she doesn't have
much time until midnight to be precise
to prepare for her trial
Ambrose tells her about a mortal named
Daniel Webster a legendary lawyer who
specializes in which law as fate would
have it he lives in Greendale Zelda
pleads with Faustus to save Sabrina from
this trial and is told that all sabrina
has to do to receive mercy submit
totally to the Dark Lord and He will
forgive her that way no one will have to
lose any hair over this whole situation
once Zelda leaves Miss Wardwell reveals
herself and we learn she is working
alongside Faustus under the Dark Lord to
get Sabrina to submit she also calls
Faustus lesser referring she is higher
on the chain of command in the high
priest and perhaps that she is actually
a demon from Hell and immortal High
Priest or not he's still a man and she
feasts on male flesh
Sabrina pays a visit to Daniel Webster
hardly the house of a world-famous
lawyer
Webster lets her in after learning she's
a Spellman but upon hearing Sabrina's
story declines to help her out
Sabrina leaves and we see a newspaper
article with the headline young lawyer
stuns nation which pans up to a wall of
awards and accolades including degrees
from Columbia Law but mixed in are also
pictures of a young girl a children's
drawing in the imprint of an infant's
foot Webster gazes as these with a
pained look his focus turned to the
picture of the young girl will soon
learn that this is his daughter who was
murdered by a killer Webster helped
defend and get free he's had a change of
heart
at the kinkle house brother kinkle
compliments Harvey on his drawings
Harvey's room is covered in gothic
graphic novel style art and drawings not
unlike that of the comics the show is
based off brother Tommy lovingly calls
Harvey a twisted little weirdo and you
can see why guess it only makes sense
that he's fallen in love with a witch
and check out the poster for Archie's
madhouse here an Archie series that was
designed to be a little more quirky and
weird than the usual Archie series
Harvey's got some good news the owner of
dr. Cerberus wants him to design posters
for the store and perhaps even work a
few shifts but daddy kinkle has
different plans
Harvey's ready to work so he's getting a
job in the mines end of story
my guess is that the mine Harvey's
family works are also the same mine
Sabrina and Agatha Dorcas and prudence
used to humiliate the baxter - paal bros
last episode midnight strikes and it's
time for the trial set in this creepy
chapel on the front door it says this
way to hell folks discretes the audience
of witnesses to the trial as we the
profane sabrina stands accused before
the infernal three who act as the judge
jury and executioner for those before
the witch court but hold your hell
horses Webster's here and Sabrina pleads
not guilty
turns out Webster has a connection to
the Spellman's it's the reason he's in
Greendale
Sabrina's dad taught him which law and
offered him help when he had none and
he's now here to return the favor the
trial begins in Faustus explains that
Sabrina broke breach of contracts and
she was courting the Dark Lord by
intending to have her dark baptism that
she willingly went into the forest that
night all while wearing a wedding dress
Webster argues that there's no
proof of courtship show him the marriage
license the signatures he'll show him
the groom which really seems to piss off
this infernal judge contract no promise
no case
but Faustus does have a contract the
book of the beast
signed by Sabrina Spellman just a few
days after she was born
Webster argues that the baby could never
sign a book the collge of the stands
elder Fiona Spellman when Sabrina was
born her dad signed Sabrina into the
book of the beast was Zelda as a witness
a bargain was struck between he and the
devil the price for marrying Sabrina's
mother was Sabrina herself back at
Webster's an apparition of his daughter
with her throat slit and covered in
blood appears to him attacked accused by
miss ward well to scare him off Sabrina
and Harvey walked through the woods and
Harvey describes the reasons he's afraid
to work in the mines as a child he got
lost in them and you wouldn't believe it
but he saw a goat like creature standing
on its hind legs the Dark Lord and it's
starting to make sense
the Gothic drawings Harvey's room his
connection with Sabrina there might be
more to Harvey kinkle than we thought
Roz meanwhile has released this list of
purge books Baxter high doesn't want
read and their protest says work as the
PTA and school board are going to be
reviewing Roz's case for The Bluest I
take that principal dark Lord
also note the Greendale Ravens versus
Riverdale Bulldogs poster at the
beginning of the scene at the Spellman's
the wake of Conor of the Warlock is
being held in Ambrose eyes a strange
looking young man at the doorway his
name is Luke and he was Connors
ex-boyfriend and it appears he was
familiar with Connors iguana and general
war lockness he's seemingly unaffected
by the death he smiles and speaks coolly
he calls the Iguana stupid not to
mention the death of his ex-boyfriend
still doesn't stop him from flirting
with Ambrose my Sherlock senses tell me
something's up here ward well on the
other hand is definitely up to something
as she glues together a special
scrapbook on Daniel Webster she then
charmed Sabrina putting her in a sleep
or trance in this trance the apparition
of Webster's daughter appears to Sabrina
and leads her to the scrapbook which
horrifies her
Sabrina confronts Webster and fires him
on the spot but Webster explains he was
tricked by the devil he made a deal with
the Dark Lord to become the greatest
lawyer in the world
and he was but all the cases he received
were defending horrible criminals
criminals he would end up setting free
it was one of those criminals who broke
into his home and murdered his daughter
Daniel Webster knows he's damned but he
pleads with Sabrina maybe he can save
her
at the trial Zelda and Hilda have seen
better days Webster argues that because
Sabrina's half mortal she is entitled to
a human trial including a jury of mortal
peers but in order to prove she's not a
witch she'll need to show that she
doesn't have a witch's mark in Ambrose's
room Luke decides to pop in for a visit
Luke reveals he's a warlock and
definitely most absolutely surely not a
vampire
despite his sudden appearance and the
emphasis on being invited but enough
talk it's time to get busy
and you can bet Ambrose hasn't gotten
action in decades being stuck in that
house as these two get it on Faustus
comes to visit saying the Dark Lord has
granted Sabrina mercy and will allow her
to live and visit her friends yearly but
only if she submits to him and begins
study at the academy Webster reminds
Sabrina that the Dark Lord is a
trickster and she decides to get her
body checked for a witch's mark the next
morning Ambrose wakes to find Luke has
gone missing but he's left his number
Ashton would notice Ambrose laying in
the sunlight here if Luke was actually a
vampire he certainly wouldn't have
wanted to sleep in and get fried in the
daylight Ambrose goes to check the
Iguana and finds it very dead he
comments that it's death was due to not
being able to live without his master
but something tells me this is a red
herring that Luke was actually the one
who killed the familiar so it wouldn't
talk in the woods Sabrina's harvey to
check her body for a witch's mark kinky
kinkle joins in on the fun - back at
school we learn why Ross has been so
gung-ho about reading important books
the PTA has set a town hall meeting for
Wicca to present their case to the
school board in three months
but Roz doesn't have three months to
wait she has myopic atrophy and will be
blind by that time it also makes sense
why The Bluest Eye was her book of
choice a book about a black woman who
wishes for different eyes Harvey kinkle
fresh off the woods and finding no mark
on Sabrina
gets scared trying to enter the mines
for work Tommy saves the day and says
he'll cover for him
Sabrina with the news she doesn't have a
witch's mark convenes with Webster and
her aunts the plan is to manned a
retrial in human court but before they
go Hilda opens a mad
chests hiding baby items including a
Peter Rabbit themed record book the
items in it were all Sabrina's meanwhile
mr. kinkle working for that father of
the Year award yells at Harvey and Tommy
for letting Harvey skip his shift in the
shaft looks like at some point Harvey's
gonna have to confront his fear and head
into that mine night three of the trial
commences and Sabrina is just about to
be stripped and checked for a mark when
Hilda barges in it wasn't just Edward
Spellman and Zelda who had a secret
Sabrina's mom and Hilda had one of their
own Sabrina was baptized one day before
the signing of Sabrina's name into the
book of the Beast a binding contract
that overrides the signing null and void
Faustus and Webster negotiate in this
quaint little private chamber and a
judgment is made due to conflicts of
contract baptism and breeding
Sabrina shall retain her mortal life on
the condition that she also attend the
Academy of unseen arts and weekly black
mass think of it as dual citizenship and
praise Satan hilda and Zelda are young
again Sabrina will not follow the path
of night nor the path of light rather
she will follow a third path both
Webster leaves with some foreshadowing
nobody's ever beaten the devil but you
just might Hilda for her saving Act has
been excommunicated from the Church of
night and Faustus must be pissed right
wrong he's happy he's gotten Sabrina
into the Academy and under his watch
where he will either bend her to his
will or break her but Wardwell has a
less forceful approach
real corruption is a thin Sidel blade
she says Sabrina's strengths are the
mortals around her her friends and she's
gonna tear their souls apart one by one
and what would be more soul wrenching in
spirit breaking then a book club but
this book club is run by miss ward well
and she's got a little something for
everyone that's it for this episode I
hope you'll stay tuned for more
breakdowns coming your way
if you liked it make sure to give it a
thumbs up and be sure to check out my
other videos see you soon down the path
of night